hello and welcome back to reality check
my name is cam and I'm back on GameSpot
for a very special three-part miniseries
of reality check all about the science
of upcoming sci-fi thriller prey it's a
joyous return for a real fan favorite
and my gosh
doesn't it look fantastic but enough
about me prey is also back unlike me
though it's completely different Podesta
and the talented folks at Arkane Studios
have entirely reimagined the 2006
shooter into a whole new sci-fi thriller
me on the other hand well I'm much the
same arguably worse what with all the
terrible aging but don't worry prey has
the ability to make me better with newer
mods and that is exactly where we're
gonna start with episode 1 of this
three-part reality check special got out
of mods
[Music]
[Music]
new remotes allow the player to unlock
new abilities and generally level up
character Morgan you as the game
progresses they work by changing the
neural pathways in the brain to produce
new effects and grant the player new
powers to help fight and survive
abort Alice won this physical remapping
sounds pretty great that is until you
learned that the method of
administration is stabbing a giant
needle in your eye now I'm just kidding
it's actually two needles but get a new
remote like this ever actually exist in
real life is it really possible to remap
our human brains and is sticking needles
in your eye
ever a good idea
I really love that the neuro mod the
fact that it does involve sticking a
needle in your eye first of all because
it's terrifying and really fun idea but
also whenever you look at the skull
that's a reasonable good way of getting
to the brain your skull is are basically
a helmet thaton built it's hard to crack
and get into so going through the eye
cavities probably one of the best ways
everyone meets Simon what biologist and
science presenter that I sat down with
Simon to chat all about the science of
neuro mods and I started by asking him
how they might actually work what's
happening in prayers that these people
are having their brain chemistry and the
neurons changed and that's effectively
what learning is whenever we gain a new
ability when we learn something new it
is effectively like parts of our neurons
are starting to talk to each other in a
different way it's a new pathway a new
circuit that is created so when prayer
they're doing something to switch these
neurons on and off and create new
pathways to give you these new abilities
so what could be triggering this
switching on and off of neurons whenever
you use a newer modern pray well the
game hints that the needles are
injecting a serum directly into the
brain and that this stimulates the brain
cells the neurons to react to light now
Simon has a theory for how this could
actually work the way I like to imagine
it when they say about a serum it might
be the serum is filled with viruses
viruses that contain DNA from algae and
bacteria that turn on the light
sensitivity of the brain cells and then
if you shine a light using a fiber optic
and some lasers or something then you
can target which neurons are switched on
which ones are switched off and with
that precision we can really alter the
brain
[Music]
fascinating stuff in fact that process
Simon just described of using viruses as
a vehicle to transport special
light-sensitive DNA from bacteria or
maybe algae into brains and then using
light to affect it is actually a
real-life scientific field
it's called optogenetics we've been
using optogenetics a lot in mice as a
research tool using them as a study
before we move it on to humans
so far they've managed to make mice that
were blind to be able to see again
furthermore they've been able to teach
these nice things they've been
effectively able to target the dopamine
sensors the the pathways that we use in
learning in the ward and so if you make
these parts switched on and you teach
unless something specific then it's like
it has learnt that there will be a
reward for any particular thing and from
this ribble to make these mice learn
incredibly quickly well that's all well
and good for mice but what about
boosting human learning which is what
your modes essentially do well imagine a
newer mod which gives you the ability to
say fly plane now it's obviously not
quite the same but last year a study
published in the journal frontiers in
human neuroscience showcased a
fascinating way of helping beginner
pilots learn to fly more quickly so
they're able to study the brain patterns
of pilots see what areas of the brain
seem to be firing what parts were most
active what parts were not and from this
use electrical stimulation a kind of cap
that they put in volunteers to make
those areas more receptive to change
more receptive to having those neurons
switched on this basically means that
these people seem to learn the skills of
being a pilot that little bit faster
[Music]
so what abilities would you take a stab
in the eye for let me know in the
comments down below now next week in
part two of this reality check
miniseries we're going to take a look at
the fabricator how close are we to
having one today could it ever be real
and what wondrous things could we make
thanks for watching everybody and come
back next week for part two of this pray
reality check special
[Music]